we stand here in a truly great city in a
truly great city region my name is Tony
Walsh
they call me long fella a falls to me to
try and sum up what makes this city its
people its communities so great with a
poem it's called this is the place this
is the place in the northwest of England
it's ace it's the best and the songs
that we sing from the stands from our
band set the whole planet shaking our
inventions and legends there's now we
can't make and so we make brilliant
music we make brilliant bands we make
goals that make Souls leap from seats in
the stands and we make things from steel
we make things from cotton we make
people laugh take that mix them a rotten
and we make you at home we make you feel
welcome we make some what happen we
can't seem to help it and if you're
looking for history then yes we've a
wealth but the Manchester way is to make
it yourself make us a record a new
number one and makers a brew while
Europe love go on and make us feel proud
that you win in the league and make a
sing louder and make us believe it that
this is the place that has helped shape
the world and that this is a place where
a Manchester girl name of Emmeline
Pankhurst from the streets of Maasai
from the streets of moss I'd let a
suffragette City with Sisterhood pride
and this is the place with Appliance of
science we're on it
atomic we struck with defiance in it in
the face of a challenge we always stand
tall bank unions in Union delivered it
all such as housing and libraries and
health education in unions and coops the
first railway stations always sorry bear
with us we invented commuters but we
hope you forgive us we invented
computers and this is the place this is
the place Henry rice roll with rolls and
we've rocked and we've rolled with our
own Northern Soul and so this is the
place to do business then dance we're
go-getters and goal setters know the
vatch ants and this is the place where
we first played as kids I mean ma'am
lived and died there she loved him she
did and this is the place where our
folks came to work where they struggled
in puddles they hurt in the dirt and
they built us a city they built us these
towns and the coughed on the cobbles to
the deafening sound of the steaming
machines and the screaming of slaves
they were scheming for greatness they
dreamed to their graves and they left us
a spirit they left us a vibe that
Mancunian way to survive and to thrive
and to work and to build and to connect
and create and Greater Manchester's
greatness is keeping it great and so
this is the place now with kids of our
own some are born here some drawn here
but we all call it home and they've
covered the cobbles but they'll never
defeat a
the dreamers and schemers who still team
through these streets because this is a
place that has been through some hard
times oppressions recessions depressions
and dark times but we keep fighting back
with Greater Manchester spirits northern
grits northern wits and Greater
Manchester lyrics and his hard times
again
[Music]
and there's hard times again there's
hard times again in these streets of our
city but we won't take defeat and we
don't want your pity because this is the
place where we stand strong together
with a smile on our face Bank unions
forever because this is the place in our
hearts in our homes because this is the
place that's a part of our bones because
Manchester gives us such strength from
the fact that this is the place we
should give something back always
remember never forget forever Manchester
choose love Manchester thank you
you